test test
test test
should be able to hear me
test
test okay cool
test test
well to all my members
we'll have to do
another members only chat because uh
because this one clearly didn't work out
[Laughter]
i apologize to everyone who pays to be
members of the chat
i don't know how to do this
yet since we just started to introduce
members uh
i can i can hear myself on my phone
so i know the sound is going through so
if you can't hear me
check your audio and if you can't hear
me i guess that's irrelevant
because you can't hear what i what i
just said okay
uh yeah this started as a member's chat
it is not a member's chat now um
but
i'll make it up to my members all the
members who are in the
the chat right now i will make it up to
you
we will do another one uh maybe tomorrow
uh
i should probably change the title
so the trailer oh my gosh guys
oh
i i i never thought ever that
they would be
showing or teasing professor xavier like
ever hey sebastian bemba nick
love the emotes that's what you get with
memberships uh sorry sebastian that this
isn't members only i
don't know how to it's i'm looking at my
studio right now and it says members
only clearly it's not
so i'll have to uh i'll have to get with
that hey andy
47 hello hello welcome welcome thank you
for being a member
sorry it's not members only chat
but we'll do we'll do another one we'll
do another one uh for just members
anyways guys
that trailer doe oh man i never thought
they would show so much in the trailer i
really didn't think they would show so
much
hey jake hedge how's it going i keep the
title wanting to scrub thanks for the
super chat
yeah apparently i don't know how to do
this yet so
but seriously
i i just didn't think they would show
patrick stewart
uh
i mean i guess technically they didn't
like show him but like i never thought
they would tease him
like it's insane
it's insane
it's crazy man i
uh so now i can talk about it i had
heard about it right so
the the it's like cool getting close to
studios but then it's like a
double-edged sword there because like
now i like if i hear things i can't talk
about it or i'm gonna get in trouble
right um so i could play a lot of things
off as like rumors and stuff like that
but like the professor x thing i don't
know if you guys saw this but like
three weeks ago maybe i had posted a
video that was like all
uh
characters
rumored for multiverse mess something
like that
and um
i talked about patrick stewart in there
and i talked about
like there's been leaks blah blah blah
uh so marvel security actually called me
and uh they were like we need you to
take this video down i was like oof okay
and that's like you're in trouble like
when the actual security team is on you
like
that's a big one jg thank you for that
super chat you're having a baby and it's
name is warren wow
that's a great name i gotta tell you
that much
congratulations on your baby
congratulations
make it so engaged andy i don't know
what that means i'm like
i just started the membership
membership so it's very new to me and
i'm i've like it literally says members
only on my dashboard right here
so
but we'll have a good time tonight we'll
have a good time tonight
uh wakanda for eva thank you for the
super chat i'm truly thinking nightmare
is the big bad you know they did drop
that name nightmare they they did
they did drop that tony
gtafan2542 thank you so much for that
super chat super appreciate it
uh i just saw a member chat
we should tell them the truth so what do
you i i have my own theories about what
the truth is
um
what do y'all think
what do y'all think right now
hey aj kedge i appreciate that yeah no
worries no i i super appreciate that
there's going to be some cool member
perks
uh coming up i'm going to do like
exclusive videos and stuff for maybe
some things that i uh you know i've
heard that i can kind of like hint at
and stuff like that i think it should be
cool uh i saw something
i saw
there skanda rao pg today is my birthday
happy birthday happy happy birthday
my family and i love your vids keep the
great work christian lynn harris hey
thank you so much thank you thank you
thank you love all y'all
the clown times thank you for that super
chat thank you thank you thank you uh
and then
mike diddy 87 thank you for that super
chat i know
patrick stewart's voice but mcavoy's
body oh that would be madness
i have a theory but i need a i need to
like i need to like grasp it a little
bit more
chris barcenas thank you for that super
chat movie's gonna be wild i'm here for
it hell yeah dude like it's gonna be
freaking crazy gonna be crazy gonna be
crazy so let's let's let me pull this up
actually i need to put it to this screen
over here let me pull up the trailer
what i originally meant to be like a
super super chill stream with the
members only has now turned into a big
awesome stream love it
okay let me see
how
what about this no what about this
what if i do
[Music]
that there we go
so there's one part
this part check this out
and i'll
do a little expansion sinister strange
so this is officially
this is officially sinister strange
things just got out of hand
oof
let me i need to
pull this up
here
so this isn't uh strange supreme
although i do think we are definitely
crossing over into the what if universe
i definitely think we're gonna see that
we actually see that in a part of this
trailer we can see an animated world
but this is one thing that has been
confirmed right here is that
this is sinister strange
i'm pulling up the super chats
so i can uh
see hear them all so i don't miss any uh
hey warren cam k thanks for super chat
i'm curious what would happen in the
movie for it to be ruined for you uh
it'd have to be something that uh i
don't know because like
no like it's really hard to ruin a movie
for me
like as far as like spoilers and stuff
like okay for example like here's a good
example so spider-man no way home
if toby would have died it would have
ruined the movie for me
and i guess i should have said spoiler
i'm sorry if if you're in this chat you
should you should probably say no way
home by now um or at least heard about
everything but from here on out spoiler
alert for no way home and i guess kind
of everything but i'm assuming if you
follow me kind of like spoilers and
stuff like that so
but uh yeah if
if toby would have died
and there was like a really brief moment
where i thought he was going to when he
when he got stabbed that would have
probably killed a movie for me like
to watch my
childhood spider-man
finally be on screen in the mcu in the
new times with with andrew garfield and
tom holland if i would have watched him
die
that would have probably ruined the
movie for me because that's also
something i feel like has
no reason
to like happen like there'd be no reason
for him to die
right so it has to be pretty extreme
uh it has to be pretty extreme
for something to like kill a movie for
me
um
jake hedge thank you for that super chat
two seats empty defender strain dies in
beginning tries to save america then
maybe
one
for one of her moms
yeah maybe since her mom's yeah she has
two moms um
i don't i don't think it's gonna be one
of her mom's i do like that thinking but
i don't think it's gonna be one of her
mom's
i think
i think this opportunity will be used to
introduce some really cool characters
like i think mr fantastic is going to be
there
um
you know maybe century maybe that's who
that long-haired person was
i think captain is going to be one of
them
for sure uh
raj mr vlogs thank you for that super
chat appreciate it i'm just looking for
some member chats here i want to make
sure i don't miss any member chats
because this was originally supposed to
be a members only one
that one sucked nugget hey how's it
going
hello hello
thank you for being here sorry it's not
members only we'll do another one i
promise sebastian i think the truth is
the villain is a variant of doctor
strange or something
okay so that's what i
that's what i'm kind of leaning towards
so i'm
i'm thinking and if you guys watch like
my breakdown or my recent videos i think
the villains are wanda variant
and strange variant and i think we've
seen those both and i think that's who
we see at the end here
like this right here i think is like an
evil doctor strange and he is now
like calling upon like evil spirits and
evil demons and gods to like possess his
body so we can get more
power like this right here
i think this is the villain of the movie
combined with a evil
wanda i i'm
i'm hesitant to say scarlet witch
because there's only supposed to be one
so maybe a variant of hers
isn't you know
the scarlet witch per se just a very
very powerful you know wanda this is not
null
i know a lot of people have been asking
me but literally the creator of like
venom came out and said this is not null
dustin harmon thanks for the super chat
um
let me actually pull this up as well
because i don't want to miss any
member chats considering that's what
this was supposed to be
um
interesting doesn't tell me okay well
that's a waste
patrick creed hello
uh where is the trailer patrick the
trailer has been out for a couple days
now buddy
uh if you haven't seen it go watch it
right now watch it right now i mean i
have it pulled up here
let's do it together let's go ahead
let's let's watch this trailer
i'll scoot over we'll pull it up even
more
let me just one second make sure i
haven't missed any more super chats
uh i did miss one jarrison diaz
apologize bro do you think that
ghostwriter johnny blaze who should show
up we need him mcu big brother from
dominican republic hey what up uh yeah i
actually think he could be one of them i
actually think the one with the long
hair actually could be him uh and let's
uh let's go through the trailer and then
and i'll talk about it but let's uh
let's give a watch together actually can
you all hear it
you probably can't hear it huh
okay
yeah you guys can't hear it dig it
think a thing and ding it
one second well
nothing ever works like freaking as
right as you want it to work huh when
you need it to work it doesn't work
i mean i have all the okay
properties
is that why
if i check that if i take this here does
that work now
there we go okay
geo ramos love from brazil love your
channel thank you so much really
appreciate that i really really
appreciate that hello everyone who's
just joining us uh jake hedge another
super chat thank you that's the finished
strange that died in the beginning the
rein
re-animated himself he dies then and
that's why she shows up with our diet
strains yeah i actually i think i
mentioned that in my
my breakdown
or the video today i mentioned in a
recent video where i said that i
actually do think they die and that's
where we get kind of the zombie form of
them and then once the finished range is
or no once the other strange is dead
then like some evil
spirits possess his body and stuff like
that that's kind of what i feel like is
going to happen at the end i think like
it could be c'thun
right the ancient evil elder god who
in the comics like wanda is supposed to
be his vessel back into the realm he's
supposed to take over her body so maybe
we see something like that with this
other strange and uh with this other
wanda that that we see i think
that would be a good story
mike diddy with another super chat thank
you so much would be cool if this movie
has a cameo from the og punisher dolph
lunch tough lundgren man
yeah can you imagine that would be
pretty cool i appreciate that super chat
i have a thought andy thank you so much
for that super chat you didn't have to
do that you're already a member but
thank you really wish they redeemed
wanda coming from a mental health
perspective we have enough villains
being villains due to mental illness gc
nightwalker thank you for that super
chat
yeah uh
i
i don't know if it's so much
i mean yes it is like a mental illness
but i don't know if it's so much that as
it is like
grief
and like
she kind of just doesn't care anymore
and is kind of just gonna do whatever
the heck she wants to do
to find her kids that's what i think is
going on here i think one it's gonna be
like like she said in the trailer like
this doesn't seem fair right she thinks
a lot of stuff isn't fair
that combined with her wanting to like
her doing anything to find her kids i
think is going to lead for
a very powerful
character who's going to be really hard
to stop
j meister 25 thanks for the super chat
28 films marvel changes reflect and
expand on their mythology all while
continuing to ramp up their stakes ever
since story three yeah it's
it's pretty amazing isn't it
it's it's pretty amazing what marvel's
done it's no small feat and it's
something that like
not really many studios have
ever done yeah
um let me see if i missed some alexander
baker thanks for that super chat
uh let me go to all here
i think i
don't think i've missed any okay
uh adwin raj thanks for that super chat
really appreciate it uh steven stem
junior thank you for that super chat
thoughts of deadpool
significant screen time post credit
maybe uh
i think he's gonna be in it i do think
we found him on that um
on that poster
um and even if we didn't i've thought
beforehand that he's gonna be in the
film i think it would just be a
perfect way to like at least make him
know the mcu is there and then if we do
our own deadpool family it could be
about him getting to the mcu or maybe
they just bring him in there and he just
runs off and it's like haha i'm in the
mcu now suckas and then like that's all
you see of him i'm okay with that i
think it would be hilarious i really
really think that would be hilarious
like they can't catch him he just runs
off uh dustin hartman thanks for that
super chat appreciate it
oh
i wonder andy i wonder if it's going to
be as big a spider-man knew at home ah
so that's a question
that
has been asked to me a lot lately people
have asked me a lot lately uh
you know
spider-man is
one of the biggest superheroes of all
time
you know
but
look at this picture i mean
stuff like this
like i feel like if i wasn't like a big
fan like stuff like this is like
really
captivating
right i mean isn't this just really
really really captivating i mean
that right there
i mean that's the shot
that's just
i mean
that alone right there
is enough to get anybody super excited
for this i mean the ultron bots man i
mean jeez
i just can't believe they showed
this
like i can't believe they showed this
it's crazy matthew moore hey thank you
for that super chat i really appreciate
it
um
so like in my mind
andy if we were all
like if everybody was like us like
everyone here in this chat i know you're
here because you love this stuff and
we're all together on this right
i would say yeah i would say it's going
to be bigger than no way home
however
the i think the general public is not
like us right
um because we have to imagine like
like okay my trailer breakdown got like
uh
close to like 500 000 views which is a
lot of views for me and i'm really
really grateful but then you think like
well that's only like
500 000 people out of like millions and
millions and mil like tens of millions
of people who were going to see
this movie like more than that right
like so many millions of people are
gonna see
this movie so many millions of people
saw spider-man no way home and it's just
like
how many of them care
right
how many of them didn't really know
doctor strange until the first movie
came out and then how many after that
like
didn't care
right but i mean
infinity war in game like that's got to
make some fans of doctor strange plus
spider-man no way home strange was you
know a big part of it so maybe i think
it has potential to be bigger but i
don't know if it's going to be bigger
john hoffman yo what is up thanks for
being here i am sorry this is a member's
only chat apparently i don't know how to
do it i will work on it
i will figure it out i will talk to my
uh my youtube manager
and ask him what exactly i i need to do
to get a members only stream going on so
we can so we can all chat very
intimately uh
samriel 83 thinks that super chat hey
cosmic do you think we'll see the marvel
zombies in this movie and do you think
it'll connect with marvel zombie series
coming up i don't know if it'll connect
to the series coming up but i do think
we're going to see a zombie wanda at
least i think we've uh if you look at
the tv spot
for the the super bowl
then you'll see that we we saw a zombie
one already
yes you are remember john i just i i
don't know how
i don't know how this got screwed up
king shawuki thanks for that super chat
yeah uh to my members who are here
watching right now again i apologize it
literally says on my screen in my
dashboard right now members only
i don't know
i don't i don't i don't get where i went
wrong but uh i will fig i will figure it
out
but yeah man this part
this part right here
oh king shawuki you you give me two
super chats i appreciate that sorry if i
missed that that first one i would have
uh i would have gotten it though steven
sim jr uh thank you for another super
chat thanks for the response of your
content oh thanks
oh that's super cool always look forward
to your videos keep it up my dude thank
you so much appreciate that
uh freyja firefly thank you much for the
video yeah thank you for being here
really really appreciate that matthew
moore i believe i said thank you but
thank you again thank you again
um
like oh man let's just let's just do it
okay oh no what just happened
did i click on the ad
rookie move
so like hold on my mic's in the way
so right here
and is it a little bit before this
where do you see the other chair no it's
not okay
so there's you can see five chairs right
1466 that was five chairs
we should tell him the truth
i thought at one point in time you could
see six chairs hold on
yeah so there's
there's six because you can see it
right here
on that chair
yeah
so there's six chairs plus an open slot
which i believe is for you know
professor xavier obviously he's got a
wheelchair right so
we should tell him the truth
i thought there was a more like defining
that's so cool and you know that's just
like
iron man tech right superior iron man
which i'm doing a video on soon
uh
yes andy a suit of armor to protect the
world oh i can't wait for this i can't
wait for this
uh mobius studios thank you so much for
that not a member but glad to be here
yeah i had a little mix up here but
thank you for that super chat glad
you're here as well glad everybody's
here appreciate you all
uh john do i think deadpool will appear
yes i 100 believe deadpool will appear
in this movie 100
100
making sure
uh i'm not sure what you're referring to
there john when he said doesn't matter
we're all fans of you and marvel
appreciate that but uh
oh if it's remembered only or something
like that yeah
no i wanna like members since they
support the channel by paying for the
memberships i do want to do a member
only one soon which we will do
but i mean this is so cool right here
clearly iron man like this is clearly
iron man technology so
i'm curious as to what
like oh
i'm curious as to what like this right
here is
like
for a second i thought like maybe
hercules
and maybe that's who we see with the
long hair
but i'm but i'm not really sure about
that now this building
it actually kind of reminds me of like
an x-men first class like the building
that they use to train
that's what it kind of reminds me of
so i wonder i wonder and i wonder if
this exists like in between
multiverse or like somewhere in the
multiverse like in between universes
right kind of like the tva because the
illuminati here is going to be kind of
like the tva go i'm punished
oh so freaking cool
we should tell him the truth so let's go
back here
all right so
now go back
that guy right there okay
i can
hear epiphany
thank you so much for becoming a member
super appreciate that very cute dog you
have there as your uh
as your uh profile picture there thank
you so much for becoming a member we'll
do a member only live stream very very
soon liz con day
conned sorry if i didn't pronounce that
right this is my favorite channel by far
oh thank you so much uh i am from utah i
am and you should just keep doing it
again ah thank you so much yes i am from
utah that is where i'm at right now uh
jonathan cahoon thanks for the super
chat last year loki was rumored to be in
the movie do you know if loki anderson
will be in it you know i
i heard a lot about that before
but i think it was just i think it was
like people putting like two and two
together
like oh it's a movie about the
multiverse and
loki was all about the multiverse and
now it's like bursted open
um
so i don't know how much of that is like
just logical thinking
and some people
guessing
or
if it's like something that's actually
rumored
i'm i'm split i think it would make
sense if it happened but at the same
time
they might focus on like really crazy
stuff here
we should tell them the truth
make it so number one oh yeah make it so
number one is that yeah star trek i got
that one yeah
what did i miss before because i've
watched all the star trek well i lied
i've watched uh
uh the next generation more than
anything in the friend the first one was
shatner because my dad was a huge star
star trek fan and i watched them all
with them
speaking of which they actually heard
that they are making a fourth star trek
uh film
so yeah
make sure i didn't miss any
[Music]
uh why what proof is there
of what
john hoffman i'm not sure what you're
talking about
uh i started watching 90 spider-man
cartoon was kid doctor strange was in
that i really liked the animated series
mark campbell's hub goblin yeah i mean
same here uh
you know i grew up in the 90s i was
actually born in the 80s
don't tell anybody
uh
but yeah i did too i mean i grew up on
all that stuff um
so yeah
just trying to make sure i didn't miss
any member chats
it doesn't look like i did
you guys are awesome i love how everyone
talks i love how
this community is brian sims hey how's
it going
look at the chair mordo about to walk
do you walk by second from right it inc
lit incorrectly when you go frame by
frame clearly and edit someone was there
they don't want to see you know what
that's an excellent point and
i
i would agree um i'm thinking there's
definitely people here
that they don't want us to see because
it would ruin it maybe their outline is
just
would give it away you know but totally
so
this right here to me
i think is mordo because mordo was
wearing like a very long like cloak uh
he had long hair and this person seems
to have long hair
so i think this is mordo
and i think there is a doctor strange
in the illuminati i think it's probably
the defender strange that we see
um
so he i think he's somewhere in there
and that could even be defender strange
walking up but i do think it's mordo
walking up right here um
this to me like i said in my breakdown i
that necklace could be black panther's
necklace you know it really does look
like it
but it could be mr fantastic you know i
think if it's john krasinski as mr
fantastic i think he'd be a little bit
more buff i think
he's bigger than this character right
here this looks like a slim black
panther to me but who knows
uh let me see i know i've missed some
super chats here
uh king shawuki do you think a variant
of doctor strange could be part
illuminati there you go just has to
write there yes i do i i definitely do
um
jarrison diaz 43 imagine that ghost
riders show up pin it stare and kill
strange like in the comments or fight
between them i oh it just went away
sorry oh i would prefer ghost writer and
post credit with midnight sun
oh or show a future team up yeah i i
think this is a perfect opportunity to
introduce the midnight suns i think it's
a really good opportunity to introduce
ghostwriter and you know some rumors
have said that he's gonna be in it so
yeah
i hope we see him matthew moore thanks
for that super chat i think it says
spoiler alert it's really small i can't
really see it
um
okay okay brian yeah alexander baker
thank you again for another super chat
and just make sure i didn't miss any
i can't i can't remember who people were
like there was a lot of people tweeting
at me today
let me let me go ahead and just see who
it was
i can't remember everyone was saying
like a lot of people were saying that
they think
this person
is going to be a member of the
illuminati like a lot of people were
thinking this so let me go ahead and
is it
[Music]
balder the brave
balder the brave that's what people have
been saying
i think i did a video on this not too
long ago as well
i don't really remember but that could
be who that really big figure is that
you know that could be who that is i was
thinking that because the long long hair
and like how big he is it could be a
version of thor
a part of illuminati i would prefer them
to have members of the illuminati though
that
we
we haven't really been introduced to yet
like mr fantastic now the tom
cruise superior iron man thing though
oh
i got a video coming out
in a few days about that because i have
some other videos planned in the
meantime uh it's so cool
the whole idea of it the whole idea of
superior iron man
um
coming in i mean it's just so freaking
cool and i have a whole theory about
what that story could be
uh andy same here watched it with my
father too kept the tradition after he
passed the tree
sorry to hear that my father passed in
2014
and yeah i've definitely watched some
star trek since since he's passed as
well got to keep it going i'll make my
kids watch it they'll hate me for it
because it's going to be so old at that
point but you know
got to do it got to keep it going
so
i don't i don't know if balder the brave
right here
like this is a big dude
for sure but like
he's big like he's tall he's not like
like it's not like arnold schwarzenegger
right like he's not
super super jacked because he's not like
really really wide he's just really just
big in general and tall
and i feel like balder brave might be a
little bit bigger than that
i was thinking sentry
long hair
i think it would be really cool if they
freaking put century in there can you
all imagine like
i think would be super cool if it was in
century uh alexander baker how do you
become a member excellent question uh if
you go to my youtube channel i believe
you have to be
on a p on a computer you have to be on a
computer so if you go
there's a join button
right here i don't believe it's on
cell phones yet
it might be on androids
maybe it's not on iphones but there is a
join button right here you can join
and
in future
in the future we'll be doing member only
live streams to where it's just members
i'll be doing videos for just members as
well
and some other cool things
coming up uh help support the channel
i've got a lot of cool stuff coming uh
that i'm really excited
i'm really excited to share with you
guys pretty soon
uh
let me make sure to miss anything
john hoffman at first i answered a
question oh somebody had asked gotcha
someone else but no worries but not a
question no worries but knowing what
yeah sorry i was like you're talking to
me talking to somebody else uh
uh just the nobodies all my buddies what
is going on guys you didn't have to give
me that super chat super appreciate it
guys
just the nobody's podcast if you guys
have not
seen their channel they're freaking
awesome they do so many cool theories
they do a lot of marvel theories they
they do just a ton of stuff
just the nobodies podcast they are crazy
cool dudes
welcome to just nobody's and today we're
gonna be talking about a crazy
spider-man theory
spider-man
right there they're so cool their
theories are awesome uh you guys should
definitely check them out because
they're really cool dudes
what's up daniel and ryan that's that's
who they are their brothers their
brothers
let me make sure i didn't miss any super
chats
uh yap camaton
cosmic do you think this is cover-up
shot but the real one are doom bots oh
good thought
and the cuffs are doom tech
because of the gray and green color
scheme doom and the illuminati i would
really love that
but i would
i would almost count like not counter
but just here's a thought to keep in
your mind
um
you you want like if you're the
illuminati you kind of want
good people with you
which is kind of my weird like this is
like this weird thought i have about
superior iron man i'm like
superior iron man in the comics isn't
exactly a good guy
like
if you know him you know what i'm
talking about he has a big god complex
and he and he takes joy and like the
suffering of people
um
so
i
i have a theory i have this whole video
coming out about superior iron man i'm
not going to spoil any of that uh
because i think you'll really enjoy it
but like my my internal thinking goes
like i question the illuminati
for wanting
for wanting someone like superior
strange
to be a part of the illuminati because
you would think you'd want like really
good people right or maybe you just need
ruthless people i don't know so that
would like be my only thing with like
doom is like would they ask doom to be a
part of the illuminati you know what i
mean but i do really love that thought
because i would really love for doom to
be in the mcu now let's talk about what
yap is saying here
and what somebody previously said before
yeah there there very well could be
there very well could be a person in
each one of these chairs right here
because marvel's notorious for covering
up trailers
right i mean
they are they're not coverius they're no
cover yes notorious for covering i
combined two words there they're
notorious for
putting things in taking them out
just think about the spider-man knowing
home trailer
where one goes don't cast that spell and
then he winks like that wasn't even in
the movie
right
so
are there people in all of these chairs
right here
i think so
if not we'll probably definitely see all
the people clearly this is a like a
court hearing
right like
doctor strange right here is being
judged he
he is gonna be sentenced for his crimes
and that's what you know that's what
mordo says your crimes can't go
unpunished
so
are all of the members of the of the
illuminati going to be there for this i
would assume so it seems like a very big
deal
um
what are they covering up
i don't know
uh andy thank you and sorry for yours as
well it's not easy i know how it feels
mr anderson did we start early uh
maybe
i don't remember what time i said it was
going to be at oh did i i said 6 30 pst
i did didn't i dang we did start early
we'll keep going
um
supporters square greetings from an
italian fan living in canada nice great
channel thank you very much
is it cold for you there but it's cold
for you there robert taylor thanks for
super chat that big person with long
hair is peggy carter oh yeah i tr i i
believe she is going to be
uh i do believe she's going to be a part
of the illuminati 100
send a link to the nobodies that's a
good
idea oh
where the heck is it
i don't even have my own chat open
i did now i don't all right hold on
go here
yes
pull it up please there you go
just the nobodies my bros
uh carlos badola thanks for the super
chat i just want to see your videos
helped me so much and really enjoying
the channel please don't ever stop ah
thanks so much man uh what's your
favorite illuminati member
um
i mean in the comics
that's hard
that's a hard one because i really love
them all
probably mr fantastic or
professor x
and here i don't know if we're getting
like superior iron man and stuff
oof
brian sims i'm not
oh you got into the super chat so
somebody else would see it well there
you go
but thank you for the super chat
appreciate it
otherwise i don't really understand that
i'm sorry
um
gc nightwalker thanks for super chat
maybe illuminati just needs those
powerful enough
to traverse multiverse the good ones
keep others in check keep your misclose
kind of thing you know and i thought
about that too because like
you know if
if you
if you're an illuminati like member like
wouldn't you want someone like a
superior iron man on your side
he's rich he has ultron bots and you
don't really know what he's going to do
like is he going to be good is he going
to be bad like
may you make a very fair point there
keep him close hey supporter square
thank you so much for becoming a member
i appreciate that we'll do some members
only stuff soon
um
trent stewart if iron man
has three infinity stones as rumored he
probably controls who's in the
illuminati
so again it's so funny because we're
like talking about things that i'm going
to talk about in a video that i'm going
to put out i don't want to like ruin it
because then you'll all know but it'll
be a good video nonetheless um
i think
hey aj
deputy 1024 i see you you always
complain i don't see you i see you um
yeah
i i think
he's gonna be so powerful that either he
formed the illuminati
because he's has his bots you know
everywhere across the earth and then
discovers the multiverse and goes well
i'm gonna put all of my bots across the
multiverse so maybe he's the one who
started the illuminati
so it's not really people deciding if
superior iron man could be a part of it
but superior iron man decided who's part
of the illuminati
that's a good point
uh
i missed something
but yeah good point trent stewart good
good good good point
yeah um
these chairs will probably be failed in
the movie
i really i really want to say that they
will
and i really want i so what i truly like
want
from this movie is and and like not the
not the whole movie to be this way
because i think it would be
maybe too much
i want there to be like one scene or a
few scenes or just like a montage or
something of doctor strange america
chavez going through just
a ton of different universes
just like a ton of different universes
and like as they go through these
different universes
like we we just see everyone
like everyone from from anything that's
ever been marvel like anything anything
the the netflix series right the old you
could even do the old spider-man
television show like anything
like i want them to go through
everything
i i want there to be so much
that
that just like your your mind's blown
right because it doesn't even have to be
like they don't even have to talk but
imagine they just go through a universe
they pop in real quick and they're like
looking around and there's wolverine
hugh jackman's wolverine and they're
just like oh wrong universe and leave we
would go nuts for that still
right i mean
we would go crazy for that
even though
it's just for like a second or two
seconds like we would all go crazy i
think the biggest thing that i want from
this movie
and it's not very
big i guess i should say
but like for me i just want a scene
because this is how i think deadpool
should come into the well i i got two
two ways deadpool should come into the
mcu one he should just
in this movie become aware of the
multiverse
and figure out that there's like a main
mcu
and then in his movie deadpool 3 he it's
about him killing everybody in the fox
universe and trying to get to the mcu so
that's one way but i would love it
if deadpool
if they like open a portal to deadpool's
universe in this movie and he just gets
so curious he like pokes his head in it
and he jumps through and he's like oh
what is this place what is this place
and then they're telling them like oh we
got to get you back and he just
bolts off he just bails
he like jumps on a train or ju like does
something and deadpool just takes off in
the mcu and now he's stuck in the mcu
and it's dr strange's fault and but
there yet like i think it would be
hilarious i just think it would be so
funny and that's what i would really
love to see i want deadpool to j like
he's not supposed to be in the mcu but
he just jumps in takes off and you can't
stop him and oh all of a sudden he's
here
all right all i need is a 30 second
scene for that to happen
so
i would love that so much um
i've missed a few super chats but i'm
getting to them
i think this is the this next one
gc nightwalker thank you again for
another super chat
feel confident saying that captain
marvel looking people are wearing
superior iron man suits like he made for
them even if it's not him so yeah that's
what i mentioned in my breakdown
if superior iron man
has successfully created a suit of armor
around the world and if he's in charge
of the illuminati why would he not make
them suits now the suit in the comics is
liquid it's not like nanotech it's it's
liquid and but once it gets to the
surface of the skin it becomes hard
so
you know you could do that for anything
now that captain marvel looking person
check this out i think it's kang
i i think it's i i think it's kang
i think it is
um
iron lad couldn't think of that i think
it could be iron lad like
i really do because
it could just be the quality of the
picture but it looks like a man like it
looks like a man
um
and i think it i think it could be iron
man i think it could be a version of
king because i mean kang's all about the
multiverse right so there's a good
version of kang out there and um
iron lad is that good version and you
know in the comics he actually
makes the ultimate sacrifice
to get rid of kang
so
we've got a couple more super chats
jake finnemore thank you for the super
chat i've loved and watched your channel
for years thank you for everything
thoughts on one is fate after multiverse
and madness also the black panther you
think to the left is mr fantastic in
your opinion white is the logo well i
super appreciate super appreciate you
sticking around for all this time thank
you so much i'm glad you've enjoyed the
content
um
as far as the black panther goes yeah no
like
i agree
it could be
and we're staring at right here right
you know it could be to me it really
looks like
t'challa's necklace
but i i have seen like the the photos
that are like touched up and like they
look a little bit better and i have seen
the logo
it's hard to tell because the photo is
not high quality and you never know if
it's just like a spot or something like
you never know but
i 100 believe mr fantastic is a part of
the illuminati 100
so yeah it could go either way either
that's to
challa and mr fantastic is there some
more or that's mr fantastic you know you
never know as far as wanda's fate
i don't think she's bad i think she's
gonna go through i think she's gonna do
whatever she can do to
to get her kids back
like really i i think she's just gonna
do what she can to get her kids back
and
she's not going to let anybody stop her
and then you're going to have people
call her evil
because of everything she did
and i think she's going to get tired of
people's crap
and just kind of do what she wants
so
i
i don't think she's evil
i just think she's gonna i think she's
the strongest being in the universe and
is not gonna let anybody get in her way
and i also do think that like the elder
god c'thun or something like that is
gonna have a part to play in this i
think
uh oh
hello
it says the stream disconnected
did it disconnect are you guys still
here
i mean the chat's still rolling
did my stream disconnect guys it says it
disconnected but everyone seems to still
be here
okay we're still here thank you cool
okay it literally it says it right here
it says i've only been live for 40
seconds and it says at the bottom and it
disconnected and i heard a weird noise
so i was like
cool
epiphany there's a bit of a hiccup thank
you for letting me know okay
perfect perfect perfect thank you
all right cool cool
okay
back to what we're saying um
i don't think one is evil but i think
there might be
someone or something kind of like
possessing her that wanda variant we saw
that could be an illusion it might not
actually be a one variant that could be
catholic
trying to
manipulate her right
but again in the
in the comics you know
c'thun
created the dark cold and when he got
you know banished from
our realm
she was
his vessel
for coming back and that's why you know
he kind of like left his mark on her and
that's where she got the chaos magic
from
i think something like that might be
going on i think a little bit of a
possession might actually be happening
that's kind of making her a little bit
evil
but i don't think she's evil and i think
by the end of this she'll probably have
some sort of a redemption
uh i know i've missed a few super chats
so let me get to those
oh you know what i think is happening
oh no here we go okay my internet's fine
uh fishman thank you for the super chat
been a big fan of two years heard that
captain marvel figure could be blue
marvel do you believe so no
i i think i think we have
one i think there could be i do think
there's two different figures there one
i believe could be
uh iron lad two i believe could be a
maria rambo captain marvel and three
superior iron man i think one of those
photos really
looks like superior iron man
uh andy every stanley appearance like
ever even like weird poster board photos
of him in every universe would be cool
that would be cool too
dang
well did you guys hear about like the
ending of of no way home
in the script it said a stan lee look
alike in the diner and that's totally
what that was and i i think a lot of
people when they saw that guy they were
like is that supposed to be stanley
i think it might be supposed to be
stanley
ritwick how's it going
hello hello hello sorry this isn't a
members-only stream i apparently don't
know how to do it
sorry i also realized i got on an hour
earlier
earlier than i was supposed to
but don't worry because we'll do a
members only stream soon i'll try to do
it this week
liz love the hype greetings from utah
utah is pretty great the weather's been
pretty nice lately can't complain
utah is a pretty great place all right
ryan spider-man thanks for the super
chat instead of king or captain marvel
it could be tom cruise iron man oh
totally and i actually like i just said
i think it could be two different people
because one of them clearly looks like
um an african-american person which at
like like more inspection
there's a photo that really looks like
um
jonathan majors
so i could think of be iron lad but one
of them really looks like maria rambo
and then
one of them really looks like iron man
like
really does so we'll have to we'll have
to see about that
uh do you see knight walker thanks for
another super chat maybe spear iron man
makes suit for professor x to walk
that'd be freaking cool right
i do want to see the wheelchair though
because i feel like it's going to be
like uh like the animated series
wheelchair like the yellow one i do want
to see it
yo dawgson film big super chat thank you
so much um
i hope this movie blows my mind i want
to see wolverine or any other x-men
besides professor xavier greetings from
mexico
greetings back to mexico um
i'm pretty sure it's gonna blow our mind
like
i really i i have no doubt that it's
gonna blow our minds like
um
i'm so excited for this movie like so
excited for this movie um
i just
i'm so excited uh bye john thanks for
stopping by we'll do a members only
stream soon
um
i think so i was talking to greg alba
from the real rejects today and you know
sometimes we do express concern like
i really hope the story is really good
for multiverse of madness and we were
talking about it and i had this thought
i was like you know this is one of those
movies that i think is going to have so
many cameos that even if
it's not a good movie
the cameos will make it a good movie
right it'll be the difference between
if they didn't have all these cameos the
movie
and if they don't have all these cameos
and then the movie sucks like the movie
could suck but if they do have all these
cameos in the movie sucks it'll still be
pretty good by the sheer fact that we
saw all these cameos but i believe that
it you know in feige we trust you know
what i mean i i think he's i think he's
got a great handle on everything and i
don't think the movie's gonna suck at
all i think it's gonna be amazing
epiphany hope you get over you're cold
gotta drop for now take care all
thank you epiphany thank you for
becoming a member we'll see you next
time take care
samurail 83 do you think we'll see the
watcher from what if and maybe magneto i
do think we'll see the watcher i don't
know about magneto
i would love to see magneto
but i don't know if we will
but like i said i hope we see everything
like i'm so fine with just every cameo
there could possibly be from like the
fox universe like
really really really really um i also
want to see robert downey junior's tony
stark e obviously it won't be r
r tony but a variant that looks like him
i don't think enough people are talking
about that
because i think that would be pretty
dang cool and black widow right scarlett
johansson returning because why not it's
entirely possible there's some universe
where
the avengers are the same they look the
same but only one thing is different
right like danos didn't come for
something
so you know
i think not enough people talk about
that uh ryan newsome thanks for super
chat do you think
dr strange is going to pull
the fake mandarin thing in the
multiverse of madness with certain
character in the movie uh
no i think this is going to be like
a very hard hitting movie i think
there's going to be a lot of
consequences
in this film and i think it's going to
be
i think it's going to change the mcu
it's going to be very real i think is
what i'm trying to get here going to be
very very very well
great wick no home is the most beautiful
gift i could ever receive because i can
personally relate to peter parker a lot
and spidey was my first hero on screen
still brings me tears yeah man i mean it
was a great
what a great movie what a great
experience it was just
like i mean when i just when i was in
the theater and i saw him for the first
like when andrew popped on the screen i
was just kind of like
dude it's real like
like everything
we've been talking about and like i
i have
insiders that talk to me all the time
every day right and they're all sitting
there telling me yes 100 percent
toby and andrew they're in the movie yes
blah blah blah i've talked to people who
saw the test screenings before yes
they're in the film
and there was still a little bit of
doubt in me like one percent and then
when i saw them for the first time i was
like wow like
wow they
they did it
it was it was incredible it was
incredible
um
oh
okay one second endless mystery do you
think we'll get an x-men
post credit scene uh
i want so badly to say yes
uh i haven't heard anything
but considering the fact that professor
xavier is going to be in this movie i
would really love if they took this
opportunity to yes give us a post credit
scene for the fantastic four
or
the x-men it'd be perfect
side note everybody all the supporters
uh i think if you've joined my live
streams before you know that mr anderson
my moderator is one of the best bots out
there and he's a great guy and he has
started his own youtube channel if you
would like to support him
and follow him on youtube he's posted
the link in the chat and i believe he
will post it
again right now
because i can't post it because i'm not
signed in but if you would like to
support him please show him some love he
has been the moderator and every watch
party we've had staying up super late at
night making sure the chats
stay super friendly for everybody to uh
you know be able to have a good time if
you guys want to support him he just put
his link in the chat right there
oh
my sister jumped in hello bella bella
icebox xbox chillin
why ice box
that's really weird that you said that
actually now that i think about that you
don't play valerant like i do
uh andy jim carrey's cable guy will show
up just like in the super bowl
commercial dude how cool was that let's
talk about that for a second it was so
funny cable guy
i love jim carrey i hope he shows up in
multiverse and madness or something all
right
i want to throw this out there
we'll end on this note
it is a valor map aj i see you there
oh sabella was replying to you oh hi
isabella hi sister
um
i want to end on this note
actually i'm going to
address this super chat first are we
going to have
the permanent classic spider-man costume
we saw at the end of spider-manoha
moving forward was it just to feed fan
service ryan knew some great question i
think it's oh well i don't know about
permanent but i think it's the next one
that he wears and it was inspired by
toby and andrew so
uh
marvel knows fanservice
but they also know continuity and
storytelling right like everything they
do isn't just for fan service like toby
and andrew had a real significant
purpose for tom hall and spider-man in
the movie right i mean
it wasn't just i mean yes it was fan
service but it wasn't just fan service
like it had
implications and they did it
for a very good reason so
let me end on this note
and it's a far-fetched idea and i admit
that i know that
what if we see batman in multiverse of
madness i know it's a stupid thought
but if you actually break down
some stuff that's happened recently
it's kind of possible
like james gunn talked about working
with marvel and warner brothers which is
dc and he said the relationship is
fantastic between the two of them
and he says that it is possible for a
crossover to happen one day kevin feige
said the same thing
and in the eternals there was a superman
reference
a superman reference
and i don't think it's going to happen i
should just clarify that i don't think
it's going to happen
but think about this
it's actually a possibility
if the studios play nice together
because keep in mind the comics have had
crossovers there's been marvel dc
crossovers
and they said superman
in
they said superman and eternals and
kevin feige said that he is open to a
crossover one day and james gunn said
he'd like to see a crossover it's stupid
i know i already know everyone's saying
no i got it i already got it but i'm
just saying
it'd be pretty hilarious if a portal
opened up and you just saw batman there
for like a split second and then they're
like oh this is a really wrong universe
and then they left it would be funny
that's all i'm saying
that's all i'm saying
it
if they open the universe and they're
like wow this is really not the right
universe like wow this is a completely
wrong
universe
i think it would be funny i don't think
it's going to happen at all like i'm i'm
pretty much 100 certain that it's not
going to happen
but when you're like me and you think
about every single possibility
of movies like this every single day
thoughts like this come into your head
so that's just a little
little intro to what my mind kind of
goes through all the time like i don't
believe it's gonna happen at all i you
know i would never say oh
but uh
in in a movie where anything is possible
and
and i mean anything is possible that
could happen and that's just a fun
thought to think about right i'm not
being serious with it obviously i don't
think batman's gonna show up
i think it'd be hilarious
but it won't happen
oh
uh guys if yeah i've seen a lot of spam
if you spam mr anderson's gonna
he's gonna give you a timeout and if you
do it enough will ban you
uh we don't want to spam because we want
uh the chat to be to be fun
mr anderson wb is hurting for cash they
might make a good deal yeah i i think uh
christian c just watched batman was
actually is actually going to be in it
hey all i'm saying is it actually can
happen
in a movie where anything can happen
it's actually a possibility i mean
marvel said superman
so
some type of
dc something exists in the mcu i mean
the little kid fastos's son literally
said it's superman so some type of
whether they have a superman
tv show or comics or something that
exists in there somewhere in the mcu so
technically
there should be a universe where
they're real
but it's not going to happen
so it doesn't matter
yes i think the watcher is going to
appear in the movie i i still
i do think like the whole guardians of
the multiverse was it was the final
episode right final two episodes like
the guardians of the multiverse
um i i i think we might see them because
we're gonna see peggy carter we we saw
that part of the shield in the in the in
the poster like that's confirmed
um
x-men summary
you know what x-men movies there are
yeah
i
i don't know how to give you an x-men
summary
charles xavier
charles and eric were best friends and
then they had differences on how mutants
should behave and appear in the world
and then they split
and that's how you've got magneto and
his group being the bad guys and then
professor x being the x-men and the good
guys
um
as far as there's so many stories to
tell sorry that's that's a hard summary
right there
maxwell chorney
hey man i think i pronounced it right
hey man i love the content after
multiverse of madness and
thor love and thunder
what's next big event secret wars newest
secret wars seems we're
trending towards incursions um
well keep in mind um
guardians 3 is going to be pretty big as
well from what i've heard
i think this all leads up to secret wars
i think
with uh
loki talking about the variants
uh with
spider-man home showing very clear
variants i mean loki showed very clear
variants as well uh
and then multiverse and madness dive
into some big
variants here
i think you know kane comes in after
that
i think some cosmic villains come in
after that and then i think it really
builds up to a big secret wars event
that's what i i think because kangas
coming
um
hopefully doom is coming
and
i think galactus is is out there on his
way as well
and uh i think i think with all the
variants the secret war storyline just
makes perfect sense i think a battle
world storyline makes perfect sense
uh ryan again thank you for super chat
if they do that warren will they have to
do that from
that from deadpool that can break the
fourth wall in order to do that with dc
and marvel no they don't have to it
could literally just be like a tiny
quick thing where it's like they open up
a portal like holy wow this is really
the wrong universe close that
immediately and just be something funny
like that again don't think it's gonna
happen but
uh faizan khan how do you think mcu
will introduce the maestro uh
are you referring to maestro hulk
i
if you are referring to maestro hulk i i
i don't think they will i'm sorry to say
that
i think world breaker hulk is what we're
going to get from the hulk and then i
think mark ruffalo might be done
doesn't mean another hulk isn't going to
come in
but i'm
do you do you think they'll make wang
not wong sorry i just saw wang in the
chat uh she-hulk the new hope
i don't think a lot of people like that
but i think mark ruffalo probably has
like one
solo hulk film in him and then one team
up hulk film
and then i think
they're gone
or he's gone
so i don't think maestro was gonna come
in sadly enough maybe down the line when
there's like a new hook or something
jonathan thanks for another super chat
thoughts on evil strange killing mcu
christine palmer as
uh if i can't have her you can't kind of
thing keep up with great work thank you
totally possible
um
i actually think
marvel might start doing more deaths
like
i really do
uh javier portillo portillo you think
the inhumans are in the movie i think
black bolts going to be a member of the
uh of uh
the illuminati we've been talking about
all day and then i forget it i think
black bolt's gonna be a member of the
illuminati so yes i do yes i do yes i do
um
tease thanks for the super chat dude
love your analysis cheers from india
thank you so much cheers back to india
uh
appreciate that i took time i try to
take my time with things put time into
it and i try to uh
i try to do a good job for y'all and
i've been trying to get better i'm
always trying to learn i'm always trying
to get better
i try i try try
i'm trying to pull up my super chats
here to make sure i didn't forget any
but it's not loading there we go
stumping i missed yours i'm so sorry
thank you for that super chat gilgamesh
mentioned alfred as well hey
there you go
right
thank you for that stumpy appreciate
that
i'm just saying it is possible
will it happen no it's possible though
and guess what if it does happen we're
coming back here
uh
uh gc nightwalker okay so you still
might have wheelchair may not want may
not want to wear suit very possible
totally but like him making a suit for
him yeah totally
you try and you succeed love from
florida i don't know what you're saying
who you're saying that to sabella
but thanks
james
legomitsis i'm so sorry i know i did not
pronounce it right but james thanks for
the super chat doctor strange shocked
look it's him seeing robert downey jr
iron man on council
and then professor x i mean that would
be pretty cool
uh it might even be uh
tom cruise's iron man because you know
the armor reveals iron man but then it's
a different person that would be another
shock too you know but i but i do think
that it would be a missed opportunity if
rdj didn't appear at some point in time
in this
so thank you so much for that super chat
and i'm kind of i'm with you on that one
andy
it would be funny if it was michael
keaton's batman
even though he's the vulture oh that
would be yeah
that's a good thought
that was a good thought t thanks for
another super chat movies i want
superman 2099 and superior iron man
do you mean spider-man 2099 because
we're we're getting that in
uh across the spider verse
but yeah superior iron man i don't know
if we get a movie
but uh
but i know
i i i believe he's going to be in the
world of respondus stumpy thanks for
super chat any thoughts on what the end
credits will be you know somebody
mentioned this before they hope it's
x-men fantastic for one i think that's a
great idea i think it would be
since you're introducing professor x i
think
i think uh post-credit with a true
[Music]
x-men of some sort or fantastic four
member in our universe like the true one
would be a good post credit
uh
mike casey thanks so much for that big
super chat i really appreciate it man
marvel has taken their content to the
next level i believe in the next five
issues there will be a crossover between
marvel and dc i can't wait you know
i agree with both things you said
they're really doing a great job
i think it would be dumb if they didn't
do a marvel dc crossover at some point
in time
like i really think it would be dumb
they did it in the comics and can you
imagine how
profitable that would be for the studios
and
some people might hate it but some
people might really freaking love it
like
like really love it
so
i think they should i think it would be
a missed opportunity if they didn't they
might have to wait till like
after the next avengers in-game big
event you know what i mean like
they probably would have to wait wait
for that but
hey kevin feige the president of marvel
studios said a dc marvel crossover is
possible
you never know
[Music]
i'm
looking for
member chats
i thought i saw one
now i apologize to my members if i'm
missing your your stuff but
uh
s h alif
thank you for that super chat do you
think the doctor strange that we see in
the trailer is not the main mcu strange
does he have a different cape compared
what we saw before
uh
no i think it's the main one
i think
the defender strange and what do they
call him sinister strange are the other
two variants and since the poster showed
three stranges and
two
scarlet witches i think that's what
we're going to see two variants of
strange and one variant of wanda
but good thought i like i like how you
think um
well okay guys i'm gonna say let's stop
the super chats now because uh i'm about
to get off and uh the stream is a little
delayed i get the super chats a little
delayed after you guys actually send
them i don't want to miss any so
let's let's stop the super chats not
that i don't appreciate it i super do i
appreciate any support
whether you're sitting in the background
just watching thank you so much for
joining whether you talked in the chat
thank you for joining sorry i can't read
every single comment um and the super
chats thank you so much for that support
i really really appreciate it um don't
forget if you guys want to support my
mod mr anderson you can check out his
youtube channel he's going to link that
down below um i have some exciting stuff
coming up guys um
i'll announce some of it soon but gonna
try to produce more content uh
also try to up the quality of my content
as well
so any
any
type of support really really helps
whether it's just moral support
commenting on videos saying hey like
your content like that that goes a long
way for me
because there's people out there that
say hey you suck
stop doing youtube right and those
comments kind of get to you sometimes so
i appreciate any support at all i love
you all um it's kind of crazy that i can
just do this
and talk to you all and be part of the
community and
you know
it's a dream come true i really
appreciate everybody um
i'll do some more live chat soon um and
don't forget
moon night's coming up next month so uh
you know that's gonna be more more uh
live streams coming up uh for my members
i'm so sorry today did not go as planned
i'm kind of glad it didn't because this
is a really good live stream and i'm
really glad to talk to everybody but for
the members we will have a members only
live chat soon i promise you i will
figure out how to do it again on my
screen right here it says members only
but clearly it's not
but we'll figure that out soon and i'll
do a members only chat i'll uh
i'll i'll do it in a members-only post
in a little bit later today explaining
everything but hey i love you all
three thousand uh thanks for everybody
for stopping by we'll do this again soon
maybe next week sometime uh but yeah
woof